the Joe Rogan experience well we were
just talking about the the Air Force
admitting that their pilots had seen
UFOs and you were telling me you
interviewed one of those violets I
interviewed commander flavor and he was
saying that this the chocolate has been
my favorite it's with an our free trial
favored flavor okay he was taught that
mean he was one of the guys that
actually went to what it what is the
word they do when they scramble and go
to try to figure out what the [ __ ]
something is but they they monitored
this thing they saw it with their eyes
they saw it with their equipment it was
actively jamming the radar whatever this
thing was it shaped like a tic-tac and
it moved so fast you couldn't track it
with the human eye they said it went
from I think they said some some
impossible number like 60,000 feet down
at 200 feet in less than a second like
whatever you could track you know a
radar as a blip blip blip they don't
know how fast it actually went they just
know it went this insane distance in
less than a second less than a radar
jump thank you and it would it would
dated had observed them in that area
without his knowledge like other Air
Force pilots that observe them and then
had you know brought it up the top of
the food chain but it wasn't something
that got distributed to everybody until
he saw it when he saw he was like what
in the [ __ ] am I looking at here and
they're like we have we've been seeing
these things and this thing with no
active propulsion system that you could
recognize there was nothing around no
fire coming out of it nothing around and
it would just just disappear because you
take off at insane Ray's to speed and
actively jamming the radar so when I
covered this on my show I said now I've
heard reports that pilots see this stuff
all the time but they never confirmed it
and my question was why now why would
the Air Force be confirming that they
saw UFOs nagas again like they've been
there's been reports that pilots have
seen this stuff forever and I'm not
saying it didn't happen I'm saying why
are they admitting it happen now and
then of course you see in this last
defense budget they put in money for a
space for work
I think the money for the space force
though isn't that because China is able
to say whatever they can do to make sure
we want to spend more money that's what
they'll do hey we saw UFO hey China Hey
look over there we gotta spend more
money that's what it's favor I guarantee
you isn't in that no no I guarantee no
no they're just now but before they
would say that's not true they're there
for us we'll go we don't acknowledge
that and now they're gonna acknowledge
it right you're probably right it's
probably something to that that it's
just about budgets and that's I I just I
want it I don't want to be that cynical
when it comes to something like that
really that's cynical I want to think
come on that's not cynical then plus two
it is you're right
but it's also cynical it's the only
reason why they're telling us is because
of coats it's both things yeah okay I it
is to point I mean look at is that a
hundred percent is well how they do it
if they need some sort of justification
for expanding their reach or expanding
their budget they come up with some
threats yeah I would I would I'm close
I'm in the dumb yeah I put it does gaps
in my knowledge that I can't believe oh
yeah and will neither / neither of those
are gonna figure anything out we're not
that guy that they're gonna call on
there's a real issue we need Jimmy Dore
know but that's see that's the thing Joe
but my whole show is that someone as
dumb as me can see through this yes I
can picked it I could put it together
oh we're gonna admit that we have UFOs
and now we're gonna have a space bar
okay I can put that together that's the
whole thing it's like if I can do this I
know they can do this they're just not
doing it I think the UFO thing is you
know I know you're probably right in
terms of like one of the reasons why
they released it but I think there's
also this when you get a bunch of like
really credible people like that
commander favorite guy when you get
actual data like radar you actually can
look at the video of the infrared
infrared camera of them tracking that
thing there's enough of those now that
people are like well what the [ __ ] is
going on and if you guys have all this
money and all this equipment is this is
this something that the Chinese are
doing or the Russians are doing or is
this something that you can't explain
and I think we're in this area where
there's so much information people who
can get a hold of so
videos and so much stuff that they kind
of have to start talking about it now
okay I you know III see how they shut
down conversations around the most
innocuous of enquiries so that's true
too they can say shame pretty hard yeah
they that that's pretty that's true too
but when you got a guy who's like a
decorated pilot like flavor mm-hmm and
he's like look I'm I don't know many
other crazy stories in my past he's not
crazy guys okay rock-solid general
all-around American Hero type guy he's
like look I'll tell you what I [ __ ]
saw and it's pretty crazy
[Applause]